it's dry eye awareness month dry eye is
when your eye doesn't make enough tears
or they evaporate too quickly and about
30 million people suffer from the
condition unfortunately that number is
rising due to things like too much
screen time on our phones ipads and also
air pollution ophthalmologist priya
gupta joins us live with tips on how to
get some relief from irritating dry eye
symptoms good morning dr gupta thank you
so much for being with us tell me is
this something that we see more of in a
desert dry climate like ours here in las
vegas
absolutely the environment can play a
big role with dry eye and those
temperatures out there over 100 degrees
low humidity can absolutely be a ripe
environment to create dry eye
can you tell me what are some of the
symptoms of dry eye and i think people
may have it at times and don't even
realize what they've got until they see
their eye doctor
absolutely some of the most common
symptoms can be
redness
irritation feeling like something's
actually in the eye
there's also some what i call
non-traditional symptoms where patients
might actually complain of blurry vision
or feeling like they're just not seeing
clearly
is it possible that your eyes can
actually be they can be watering because
they're trying to overcompensate
from being too dry and they're you have
tears running down your face but it's
actually a dry eye condition is that
possible
absolutely that's the hardest one to
convince patients that they're having uh
related to dry eye because patients will
come in and say well how can i have dry
eyes my eyes are watering all the time
but it's your body trying to compensate
and create tears but in dry eye patients
they just don't make
the best quality tear
so dr gupta what trends are you seeing
in this condition and what are some ways
that those who suffer with dry eye how
can they find relief
well i think you know one of the most
alarming trends is that i'm seeing dry
eye you know we traditionally think of
it as a disease of aging or maybe
related to hormonal changes but i'm
seeing this in my 20 30 and 40 year olds
um possibly it has something to do with
our digital lifestyle you know whether
you're at work or at home we're
constantly on screens and and using our
eyes
um in different ways than we have in the
past
when patients come in and ask about what
they can use for dry eye relief i like
to recommend sustained complete
preservative-free lubricating eye drops
it's really important to choose a
preservative-free artificial tear
preservatives can be toxic to the
surface of the eye
i'd encourage everyone out there to try
sustain complete preservative free
lubricating eye drop because a single
drop has been shown to provide up to
eight hours of lasting relief and you
know patients uh whether they uh
realize it or not you know we're busy
and people don't like to put things in
their eyes all the time and so it's nice
to choose something that has long
lasting relief
okay well thank you so much and of
course i'm sure you recommend that
people see their eye doctor if it
persists we'll have a link where people
can get more information thank you so
much dr gupto we appreciate your time
this morning